talks Joe D Roa here and I am on the
road starting in the new year I want to
apologize to Denver Phoenix and Salt
Lake City that those dates were unable
to happen when they were scheduled but
they are being rescheduled for 2024 so
stay tuned in the meantime if you're in
New York City January 13th I'll be at
the grar SE Theater February 8th I'll be
at basement East in Nashville February
9th I will be at the underground in
Charlotte North Carolina February 15th
San Francisco at Swedish Amer Hall
February 16th Hollywood California the
peppermint club and the House of Blues
of San Diego on February
17th uh all of these tickets are
available plus additional tickets for
shows in Palmdale California Portland
Seattle Washington All Dates all shows
all information all ticket links
available at Joe D
rosa.com come see me out there all of
these shows I will be doing my new hour
I never promised You a Rose Garden and
of course if you're in New York City and
you want to come on down to Joey roses
we got a new website Joey roses.com get
all our info there but I can tell you
right now we're open every single day
starting at 11:30 I'll see you there or
I'll see you on the road there's a big
Illinois run in November leading up to
my comedy special at the Vic in Chicago
on December 1st and 2nd the second sold
out as you guys I hopefully know uh and
so we edit two shows on the first all
will be taped and all if you have a
ticket to of those shows you'll be
eligible to win uh a flight hotel and
trip to the set of Impractical Jokers
I'm choosing one ticket out of those
four shows uh December 1st is still on
sale right now but it's going fast
savano comedy.com hope to see you guys
on the road taste bu they coming to the
mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools going to fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they
coming to them hey welcome to t a s d
buds solo chant means app flying so s is
away doing his special but we've got
some guests in the house the boys from
stuff Island are here yeah I love these
two guys Burt Ernie yeah I'll save it I
saved it they bleep the curses so try to
keep it to a minimum do they really this
isn't that pig show you do Queens what
they put this on Sesame Street this is a
classy show that we do here I just want
to ask how no cussing well you can curse
it's going to get bleep though oh okay
yeah go ahead I'm dead serious half my
is going to be cursed
uh this is I thought you set this up for
us cuz this is our this is ouro this is
our identity no some fans sent us that I
don't mean to say some fan I'm sorry
that I'm blanking on the artist's name
do you live with
s he lives in my head
rentree as they say I think that's how
this came about cuz Chris and I bunked
up for years you guys are roommates are
you not yeah we're lovers yeah yeah yeah
are you still roommates no now Shan yeah
I'm living in Shane's place now that's I
was texting with Shane last night yeah
yeah how's he doing I go bro you he text
me this is classic Shane this is classic
been going for a what a Shane
Gillis is just so you know who the Shane
I'm talking about he texts me out of the
blue I haven't not that we're not
talking or anything I just haven't
talked to him in a minute text me out of
the B he goes we used to be boys once
right you know what that is that's the
volleyball setup Spike cuz you know
what's going to come after that yeah an
insult that's him that's him sitting
in his that's like I picture him sitting
at the in the office in scar in Scarface
with the mound of cocaine thinking
everybody is his enemy now so he texts
me and he goes we used to be boys once
right and I write back and I go yeah bro
you move and you don't even tell me like
what is that and he just writes back
hahaa yeah I did dude yeah what are we
talking about here and then like he goes
come to Austin and hang out I'm like
yeah I guess I'll see you in
Austin I'll book a trip yeah I'm going
Monday I can't wait so you moved up in
the shanes Y all right now did you have
to keep all the uh Abraham Lincoln
memorabilia I tried to keep as much of
it as I could I got Hitler posters up
there I got all kinds of important stuff
so much boring history up there
where I was like you're not a history
guy if I was I wouldn't have it on my
walls look I'm a Star Wars guy I don't
have it all over my walls what do you
put on your walls art artwork like what
kind I have a lot of paintings on my in
my New York apartment a lot of paintings
yeah yeah what what's your like what
kind of art do you like uh abstract all
right yeah Chris got blacked out during
quarantine and purchased top 20 most
popular art did you really he went to
art.com start I was just picking out
stuff that I liked uh I couldn't name
you an artist or whatever but I I I I I
really am not good at that I'm not very
schooled but uh I do playing YouTube
videos she's already
bored what kind of art do you like I
don't knowy miky's face popping up on
YouTube has anybody ever looked more
aggravated
than than me looking at feni yeah uh no
I I couldn't name you an artist I'm I'm
not very good at it but uh like Picasso
kind of abct
yeah mostly modern I I I everything I
own is by a modern artist who I'm not
familiar with I just went to a thing and
I saw somebody's thing and I was like I
the two two two uh paintings that I have
or compositions I should say that I have
on my wall that I actually think are
very cool and I don't say this to be
like I'm a great guy but I went when I
lived in La I went to a exhibition in an
art studio of um it was all art that
homeless people did that's sick and I
bought two paintings from two guys you
got to wait for the toy cheap art
huh yeah just low price I said I'll take
that one the guy bit my
hand no no it was it was it was a little
pricey to be honest with what are you
going to do
haggle yeah get them down but uh no they
were they were they were really amazing
people and uh and the art was really
really really incredible uh and I bought
two things there but uh yeah I don't
know just go to you know see something
at a place they were just always good at
art or they were just brilliant and just
so up that they were just like
I'm just going to start painting I think
that they were probably artists I got
the impression that they were artists
that fell on hard hard times versus a
guy that was just down and out that
started creating art I think that's the
story Ray L montin yeah like he was
homeless and just grabbed the guitar and
it was just like a savant really I think
so no no kidding yeah I imagine that
whoever ever set up this show in La was
looking to make a book and took a nice
fat chunk off the top I wonder it's like
it's one of those events where you can't
ask a lot of questions because it's not
going to go
well bite you how much goes directly to
the artists yeah I start going up to all
the artists I think they're
screwing muy in the in the studio the uh
but yeah it's like a weird is there one
artist that just shits in his palm and
slings it at an empty canvas the uh
i' pay a lot for that so would I
do um but yeah did you but wait did you
really start collecting art over or she
I was no I I I did I started like I just
I don't know I get so sick of like you
know you look at social media and it's
like always so shitty even like YouTube
algorithm it's like the stuff that it
suggests for you to watch is always dog
and uh so I just started watching
like art documentaries like I can't I
want to learn something and then yeah
yeah I just bought like a bunch of like
shitty like how to be
pretentious yeah yeah exactly if you
train your algorithm on YouTube I've
done very well yeah it's pretty magical
if you get it I got mine where I want
mine now and it's like I get like I love
it it's like documentaries about like
like retro games that that like were out
of print and never premiered in the
States and it's stuff that I really like
like yeah a lot of like a lot of like
old TV shows about like hauntings and
stuff you know like it's good my Twitter
is violence and and politics somehow I'm
not into politics but it's like all like
death videos and like fight videos my
Instagram's all food and then I follow
it's perfect I'm trying to I went
trigger happy on Instagram too early and
now I'm following too many people that
are going to notice if I unfollow nah
they won't so I'm just going to I got a
lot of muting to do I got some of this
when they find out if you did have a
relationship with them in some
capacity they send you a message going
yo what the happened you unfollowed me
and you say well I have somebody taking
over my account and they're doing it on
a professional level just through the
industry now yeah well I can't say that
now that you've said
it true cut that out yeah yeah pimp cut
that out no but yeah the uh that's VI
painted that I know that's how I it up
uh that's not bad but it says on it now
says that's not the finished product on
either side it says enough
already uh so on the left side it says
e what are you talking about it's not on
there yet smiley face no no no I know
I'm saying this is a work in progress
that we were shooting in my apartment
and I held that up cuz pimp said hold up
this thing you're painting oh got that's
it's it now the finished version of it
says enough already it says enough down
the left and already on the right but
the enough is spelled it's it's like a
contracted version of each word word so
already is spelled a LR d
y you understand yeah yeah yeah yeah are
you trying to make it better I don't
what are you saying what do you mean
what am I saying I'm saying the finished
painting says enough already on it that
that's not the finished pain okay but
what is that what is the point are we
supposed to go oh no I'm just saying
that's not the finished painting this is
why I don't get in a painting yeah I
don't want this you ask me why I wrote
those words on it no just why did you
even say anything I guess is just it
doesn't Elevate the painting that much
no it
does if you saw it it does all right I'm
saying I guess I'm saying is I'm saying
that's not
finished that's all I don't know I'm
proud of you Joe thanks keep at it man I
I painted a lot of dark uh stuff last
year yeah yes and now you're all happy
no that's the point of the
wording saying like enough of this
aren't you tired of smiling for no
reason it's all terrible 1 million per.
yeah there you go you get it you get it
see I'll show you that God I'm about to
be homeless I'll show you
that uh go ahead what were you going to
I thought you were going to say
something no I just look like I always
am I want to congratulate you for what
wearing the worst pants I've ever seen
in my life dude suck my these are
wonderful these are beautiful pants what
are these pants in camera know I tried
to say something cords with protective
skate P I'm a skater and a painter now I
fall this is why I wipe my paints when
pain smiley face they're they're they're
thick cords buddy they're the thick stay
your Lane right there's basic Lanes
there's other higher level Lanes this is
a higher level Lane yeah I D down for
you well it's not done yet he's he's
going to paint enough already I down
like when you go
to
yeah I'm going to have homeless pin
spray paint enough already on both pants
why do they have the big patches on the
front I don't fing know Todd Snider did
it huh he's an artist who's Todd Snider
look it
up no I'm really asking did did did they
I think I look good I didn't say you
look bad I said those pants are the
worst pants I've ever seen where do you
want me to start you and your face look
good thanks the top half of you looks
good yeah cuz it's a hoodie and you're a
monkey those
pants something you could digest
yeah I I'm sorry that I can't digest
your pants that have a knife pocket on
the side it's for a hammer to beat the
it does have a hammer loop on the
left side nobody wears corduroy chunky
corduro and does and does house the girl
in the room no Carpenter wear thick
corduroys no of course they don't they
can't afford them you can't
you can't get enough tan today dude you
got Tan in the sneaks you got Tan on the
socks dude I lose my tan in the in the
winner on my face and I have to make up
for it you know
uh you're in a full sweatsuit yeah yeah
yeah this is how this starts to get
everybody fired up donuts maybe I
thought about CH I know what you're
doing I like this your psychological
Terror it's uh you're going to have so
many beeps you're going to have so many
beeps cussing uh yeah who gives you
no they'll B they'll bleep it but but
you're going to just have a lot of
bleeps I'm just telling you that's my
personality I'm not changing it for you
Joe you are the best
garbage come that should show should be
you when they get too famous and leave
like Ron Howard did on Happy Days you
should take it over and it should just
be called I am
garbage and it's just you sitting there
just talking to the camera pain like
this Bob Ross dog
pting
pain uh all right we should P this
marshmallow peep off the screen it's
firing me up we should paint we should
we should pitch that to we should I am
spin called I am garbage and we'll go
into the studio just me and you I like
that that would be funny man nobody's
ever done that with a podcast you go in
and do like like we're going to
do just someone else fear like fear of
the walking like we're the fear The
Walking Dead of are you
garbage it's almost the same title it's
in the same universe but it's just you
know uh all right just you off camera
going be
honest be honest be honest no you told
me in the elevator yeah take those
pants off now today's battle we'll get
to the battle we'll get to the battle no
let's keep talking cuz I don't have 30
minutes on a donut trust me you'd be
surprised at how long we can go on this
but but but we'll get to it we're not
we're not there yet let's talk no no I'm
serious I want to talk to you guys about
food oh okay because you guys you guys
are food guys like you're you're es
especially and I don't mean to qual qual
uh quantify qualify but especially you
you got the cooking show but I've been
when Shane still lived in that building
I would go there was a couple times at
his apartment and there was like
wonderful like Aromas coming out of your
place 100% like like it smelt like like
a Nona was in there like cooking for
real so what's your tell me like your
relationship with food I'm not being I'm
not being D my relationship with food
honestly I'm really asking you
simplified cliffnotes version my
brothers beat the out of me uhuh and my
mother was a night nurse and my dad was
working and the only way I could get
them to to stop abusing me was to make
them like I started with grilled cheese
and I would make them like cheese steaks
W and make them food uhhuh so they'd
ease off and be like you're a good
kid then I started it's the same I
started cutting my own hair it's like
you you you learn this is a trait and
you do cut your own tool that you should
use for for the betterment of yourself
and your family you know how to cut your
whole head by yourself yeah really I
need to cut I was going to cut it today
I'm way I'm way off I got a bont how do
you do the back I just by touch and
failing for two five years but you know
how to do it now oh yeah but your hair
looks good sixth grade all right so what
no I'm real are you serious what yes I'm
I'm not used to you being sincere a
little not real he's got he's got a bolt
in the chamber he's going to something
I'm not I'm not I'm really asking you a
question here nice pants do you
have they're not they're nice pants
where you get them from I'll I'll do a
makeover for you be honest you got those
from Wayfair didn't you I got these
from is that a Furniture website yeah
yeah I had to unframe them
wait a minute wait a minute you're real
the thing about your brothers I I really
do want to know this are you are you
cool with your brothers now uh one of
them the other one is uh living with my
ex-girlfriend in California what yeah
dude yeah let's beat this donut you
wanted to talk about Donuts so so cuz I
was going to ask cuz you said they would
beat you up so much does that carry into
adult I didn't have siblings so I always
wondered does that carry into adulthood
like one magical day in Lake w Paul pack
when I was in high school I took my
oldest brother down and changed the
course of all of us like you you beat
his ass yeah I choked him out and then
after that went to sleep he didn't go to
sleep but he was punching the like the
my head like like this and then in the
ground my mom's almost throwing up
SC my dad chuckling smoking a butt out
front like you know wow dude come from
it dude yeah yeah you come from it but
but like was uh was there was there a
like was there a moment where where he
sat down with you after that and said
hey dude like I know we had a rough go
of it but now I I'm sorry no it's just
it's about respect it was two dogs like
that's it I shared a bedroom with my my
middle brother I'm the youngest of three
my middle brother and I shared a bedroom
till he went to college we shared a bed
till he went to high school and then we
got bunk beds wow zero space so we were
just violent right aggressive do you
guys kick it now like no cuz he's in one
the one I talked to is in Delaware the
other one I dated this girl for 5 years
and then is that the one that you lived
in the room with yeah the one that is
dating my ex he was like my Irish twin
he was only like a year and two months
older than me Jesus God yeah happy
holidays everybody so the Delaware
brother do you do you like I'm saying
like can you guys pal around now like
when you visit stuff okay okay he's got
a wife and kids oh that's great he's
nice yeah he's he's an electrician union
electrician married a doctor so you
learned to cook to avoid violence like
some sort of prison yeah thing yeah got
it cuz I get home from school I'd make
everybody a sandwich calm them down and
then we go play football and you got
better and better cuz I was watching
your cooking
show what's it called again look at dish
okay Shane named it look at dish cuz he
likes to call me a the uh can you
beep that or no can I keep that oh
that's fine nobody cares about that word
exactly the uh no uh I watched I watched
a bit of this and I really enjoyed it
and I was like man Tommy like really
knows how to hook yeah like this is this
is this is for real like he's he's going
I watched the brazed the short ribs one
cuz you were on it and I was like wow
man like like this is this is not like
let's throw something together no this
is like no dude we're going through it
here and then we just run it like a
podcast so it's like it's F you both on
every episode yeah Oh I thought it was
just I thought the one I watched just
happened to have you as a guest no no no
he does he doeses the cooking he does
the cooking I'm just not allergic to
anything in my ear talking
shits okay so so you guys both this is
both of your show so Chris like what's
your thing with the food with food I
mean I I don't know anything so that's
what
I that's what that's what I bring you to
table just signed up for college cooking
College yeah I'm const surprised by what
he's doing now he knows how to balance
flavors yeah I'm doing it I salt fat
acid heat I know what's going on I I
actually need a bit of a CR
come over no I mean I my my parents
didn't we chicken par and egg noodles
that was everything yeah every
meal is no is no small feed a good
chicken parm is a that's a chicken parm
app on there yeah I actually need a
crash course because I I was on my way
to being good at cooking and I was doing
well for myself for a while something
happened during the last like two I
would say year and a half
I think part of it is just I got so fed
up with my apartment and so fed up with
the kitchen in it and and the things not
working properly yep that I lost mhm I
lost my interest in doing things
correctly cuz all I could think about
was like and then I'm going to have to
clean this and I'm and and it just got
it was so cramped it made me crazy and I
have
to I I cook now and like I'm not saying
it's bad but like I'll cook and I'm like
this just doesn't taste right man like
something is gone I lost something I
will say the balance between your peace
of mind and your environment and the
Aesthetics of your environment it's much
like going into your bedroom you want it
clean you want the the lighting the
Ambiance all that stuff lends itself
into having a peaceful cook and it's
Serene in a way it's like therapy for me
I love cooking by myself this is comedic
because it's just it's Mayhem you're
under time constraint you got three
cameras on you sorry and you're just
like worried about time and temperature
right and flavors then you got to it's
out to the world so it's like another
lens that you can't imagine in terms of
pressure but when you do it yourself you
should just be very peaceful it should
be an escape from all this other stuff
you do the other thing that's tough too
is and we talked about this with Todd
Barry um but like I get
like this is going to sound sadder than
it
is out of your mouth I doubt
it this is going to sound a little
sadder than
this folks let's talk about game time I
love game time they're a longtime
sponsor here at taste buds at this point
uh why do I love game time because game
time allows you to buy tickets for any
live event you are interested in
attending whether it's sporting or music
or theater or comedy in the exact way
you want to purchase tickets to attend
that event what does that mean what it
means is you don't have to buy the
tickets way in advance you don't have to
worry that there's better prices
somewhere else you don't have to worry
about what it's going to look like from
where you're sitting game 's got you
covered in every way they are offering
the best prices available they are
offering last minute ticket deals they
are also Ava offering you uh uh seat
views so you can see what it looks like
from the seat you are purchasing H and
they have deals on tickets right up to
the start of the event I love game time
trust me this is the way to go if you
don't want to have to worry about a ton
of pre-planning and a bunch of nonsense
and stress and trying to figure out best
way to go to
the get to the event enjoy it and get
your tickets the best way possible
through game time so I want you to take
the guest work out of buying tickets
with game time I'm telling you folks I
do it all the time and it's just the way
to go download the game time app create
an account and use code taste buds for
$20 off your first purchase terms to
apply again create an account and redeem
code t a s bu u d s for $20 off download
game time today last minute tickets
lowest price guaranteed this episode is
sponsored by beam dream beam dream
powder what is beam dream powder well
beam dream powder is hot cocoa hot cocoa
that helps you sleep and it's got no
sugar added and it's now available in
delicious seasonal flavors like cinnamon
cocoa sea salt caramel white chocolate
peppermint better sleep has never tasted
better did you know that poor sleep can
cause weight gain it can cause mood
issues it can cause poor mental health
it can cause lower productivity did you
know I know because I sometimes sleep
poorly and all of those things have
happened to me and I really don't like
it a recent clinical study in fact
revealed that dream can help 93% of
users wake up feeling more refreshed and
93% reported that dream helped them get
a more rest ful nights sleep I've used
it I enjoy it I like it so check it out
because it's helped me sleep better I
bet you it helps you sleep better anyway
if you want to try beams bestselling
dream powder take advantage take
advantage of what their biggest sale of
the year and get up to 50% off for a
limited time when you go to shopbee
docomo auto applied a checkout no code
is necessary again that's shop
beam.com tastebuds for up to 50% off
folks if you haven't finished your
holiday shopping yet don't panic I'm a
guy that loves to panic I'm telling you
not to panic and I like that I don't
have to panic when I'm dealing with
Uncommon Goods Uncommon Goods a place
where you can find incredible original
gifts at uncommongoods.com you're going
to find the absolute best gifts for
everyone in your life we're talking to
your moms your dads your te teens your
in-laws your besties your worses your
one and only's all right this is not
stuff you can find anywhere else hence
the name Uncommon Goods they've got
unique and creative gifts often Handmade
by Independent Artists and makers so
you're going to skip the gifts that
scream last minute those are very
obvious you're going to find something
truly original at uncommongoods.com and
nobody's going to know that you were
able to get it as easy as you were uh
I'm telling you I I like this the my
favorite thing they have
they have a create your own real uh
viewer remember the viewfinders when
you're a kid the red thing you'd look
into and
you they have a thing where you can
create your own put your own pictures
into it it that's so cool to me uh
they've got some really really cool
jigsaw puzzles that I like quite a bit
that are very unique very interesting um
they've got uh this thing called a
booknook that I like quite a bit uh it's
got a little thing where you can you
know when you're reading uh it's like a
peaked thing and you put the book on it
so it stays open to the page we're on
and then there's a little shelf for your
coffee so you can just have it set up at
your table and maybe you go to your book
every day and you you you you just you
pick it up while you drink your coffee
it's Unique it's interesting it's cool
uh I'm talking mainly about gifts for
men theoretically right but they've got
gifts for everybody okay I'm telling you
folks the selection is insane the
products are high quality they're unique
and again often handmade or made in the
US so get 15% off your next gift go to
uncommongoods.com
tastebuds that's
uncommongoods.com tastebuds for what for
15% off don't miss out on this limited
time offer Uncommon Goods we're all out
of the ordinary sometimes I get a little
down about being a bachelor and cooking
for
myself sometimes I'm
like I'm going to make this whole meal
and then like I'm going to what I'm
going to sit here and just eat it like
like there is a little element of that
sometimes it's kind of a sad thing I
know I know no he's he's you're the same
way if you were just if you were cooking
for yourself you'd be super sad your
favorite thing to do is try this try
this try this try this you're right
there's nothing better than giving a
friend or a loved one or a side piece a
nice piece of short red I understand
even when you would cook for yourself
and you'd make a meal that is only big
enough for one person you'd still give
half of it to whoever else was in the
room yeah just CU it's like you got I
need to see someone else react well just
like the levels of painting like there's
levels of like here's my personal Cooks
I know exactly what's going to fulfill
me keep the time short keep it
simplistic and then you have cooks that
you want to impress you want to extend
the time and make it a party that's
interesting that's interesting the idea
of is
that it's radi great question oh yeah
that's they don't bleed the radiat you
don't have a to do that I can say
that uh this isn't my place I know yeah
yeah but yeah the uh but um uh I guess
they don't but yeah you can hear that I
didn't even know there was a radiator in
there so I can't it's okay I know it's
distracting I didn't even notice until
you said something but now I can't not
notice
um that's interesting having different
dishes saying oh I'm not going to you
don't do that when it's just you never
thought of that cuz my favorite thing to
make is is Sunday gravy and I do it I do
it solo all the time I doesn't it like
take your mind off of all the dumb stuff
it does it does when I have the room and
the time to do it yeah but you know what
I find myself doing in New York you know
I got this house now elsewhere that I go
to and uh and and that's a that's
different now because now I it's like I
can go and it's like it's a retreat I
can hop in the car I can go to the store
I can get what I need to get I can you
know yeah here you know like for
instance if I don't go get everything on
Saturday I wake up on Sunday and I don't
feel like running out of the house it's
Sunday I want to relax I want to have a
morning I'm having some coffee next
thing you know it's 12:00 and all the
Arab women gut the meat
market you know what I mean you're like
I didn't go to the store yet then you go
and you're like they don't have this
because it's Sunday now they have so I
got to get that and then and it just
starts to kind of snowball next thing
you know you're putting it together at
300 p.m. yeah you're like this isn't
going to be ready till 9 it's your
whole meat gravy well you're also saying
that I only do a meat gravy yeah so
you're doing meatballs you doing pork
you're doing beef I me personally I
think the perfect Tri the perfect the
Holy Trinity yeah is I like to do turkey
sorry I like to do beef I like pork I
beef
meatball no here's here's and I'll
explain my my my reasoning I like to do
beef meatball pork spare ribs bone in
like that like the St Louis ones the big
ones yeah and then chicken sausage whoa
Italian chicken sausage now spicy I'll
do spicy and sweet or whatever but
here's why I like it cuz you're getting
three meats across three chicken sausage
um if now meaning I don't mean like the
pre-made
precooked you
know chicken sausage with Parmesan
cheese you know that like that
that I mean like you know whatever brand
you buy Primo whatever like they have a
chicken version got a good sausage yeah
they have a chicken version of their of
their sausage yeah so I like to get the
chicken sausage I like to get beef for
the meatballs yeah and then I like to
get the pork ribs and then you're
getting three meats I I don't like the I
try not to eat ve anymore why ethical
just it's hard to justify I mean I'll
eat it yeah but it is unethical it's I
mean look it's all up you could you you
want to go to
a h northamp where where we going New
Hampshire New Hampshire North Hampshire
he wants to slaughter a pig a cow or a
bear it's all o I need Bear yeah this
guy's he's like I'm overrun with angry
and and
V's no no no I just ve you know what it
is this is what it
is remember in the Karate
Kid when uh Mr Miyagi no no no remember
he played the prank on them when they're
in at the Halloween dance and they chase
him and they beat him up real bad at the
fence his bike in the dumpster yeah yeah
no no it's when Miyagi saves him that
bike one's when they run him off the
hill but when they beat him up and
they're dressed as skeletons mhm they
they beat him up really that's a grab
it's disturbing like if you
seriously Jesus Christ if you watch that
scene again like I'm serious it's
disturbing
great for that reason
like fake kicking somebody it's like the
uh I won't have you talk bad about the
Irishman in
my stop it's not good just stop
something something good to put in like
background music for when you cook seven
hours of gravy a masterpiece but we
don't need to
digress they beat up Daniel in that
scene and then there's the part where
the one guy goes dude he's had enough
like that's enough and the one kid's
going no no mercy it's say Mercy that
blonde man he was scary as yeah and he's
it's crazy that to me is VE ve is the
the the first part is like look it's not
great but it's like yeah the kid's kind
of asking for it he sprayed water on us
and we're beating him up now the part
where Johnny starts going no mercy and
he he never has enough to Li say that's
ve where you're like dude you're taking
it into a place now where it's like
depraved it feels like yeah yeah vagra
like that keep over I would I wouldn't
eat that any it's so good I also heard
lamb is is is lamb is like that too I
just had it for Thanksgiving a cook a
rack of lamb man lamb is unel so good
wait what do they do to Lambs just the
fact that it's a
baby oh the only animal can Lambs grow
up the only I think they're Lambs yeah
they get jobs eventually do you know the
only animal that is taken care of is the
um uh what do you call the the Korean
high-end beef wagu yeah those one
they are massaged it's not that easy Joe
it is if you're civilized he's
uncivilized if you're a human being what
are you going to do if you get on Fon
you like I'm sorry Jimmy I would turn
that down in a heartbeat you massaging
they get they get
massaged and fed beer so they're in a
constant state of spa I know I know it's
it's tension and but I mean look there's
there's there's there's free range
chicken there's you know there's there's
there's fresh caught Sea seafood not
Farm raay whatever you know I'm not look
I'm not saying that any of it's great
I'm just saying with v a little too much
for you it goes a little too far I'm
like I I let me ask you something Have
You Ever Had a ve Beef Pork
meatball many times now I have a second
part to my argument but go ahead there's
there's no comparison you go 8020 beef
you're not getting anywhere near the the
texture and the moisture I uh here's
where I disagree uh I I I'll I like a
beef and pork meatball too I think I
think you know what I'll do you want to
hear the little thing I do sometimes
with meatballs yeah you sing it to him
yeah you'll enjoy this I'll get fatty uh
I'll get fatty pork chops yeah I'll dice
finally diced the pork chop yeah and
I'll mix that in with the meat with the
ground beef so then the meatballs have
literal chunks of pork yeah throughout
do you know those meat grinders you can
buy that you know like pasta rolls you
attach to the side of a piece of wood
your your boo block the meat grinders
are not expensive like 30 bucks you can
throw that all in make your own sausage
make your own meatball that way yeah cuz
it's more evenly mixed instead of get
one big chunk I like I like though the
novelty of cutting a meatball open and
being being like look there's like
there's like meat there's pork pockets
in it you know what I mean like it's
interesting but um but I actually think
the ve the ground ve adds a little too
much of a game
uh flavor to to a meatball personally
mhm it's it's a it's an intrusive flavor
I think in a meatball to me versus the
other game is a very basic white
thing with you've never tried actual
game me no I've had a lot of game I
might be using a bad a bad term for it
game is right yeah you think it throws
off the game's tough isn't it no g a
flavor profile like venison is G you
gator Gator is a very G that's why they
deep fry it so you don't taste anything
it stinks it's just it's it's robust it
tastes very strong in the opposite way
of what you're used to in terms of meat
and chicken which is very
balanced it's got a it's got a very rich
robust flavor to it drinking aren't
juice if they brushing your teeth
something's up there yeah yeah goly now
here's the thing let's get a counter I
think uh G is the wrong term but there
is a flavor that that grounds ve has for
whatever reason that when it goes into a
meatball it's it's it's kind of be in
the M the Ball Hog it's like this is my
show now and I'm like I don't know man I
kind of like the beef flavor better how
I feel about tomatoes on a sandwich oh
really Tomatoes take over yeah get I
love them on certain sandwiches I love
them on a hogy and I love them on a BLT
It's gotta be BLT 100% you got to put it
on and eat it right away though yeah no
listen I'm very picky about the type of
tomato going on to a sandwich and how
it's cut and presented and whatever I
agree with that yeah but um but but what
is do you see what I'm saying though
with the ve thing do I do I don't know
what the term is I think you can you can
also adjust the percentages of all the
meats and number two panko soaked in
breadcrumb or panko breadcrumb soaked in
milk and you you ball it and then mix
that in the
moisture it changed my life my who's a
chef in New Orleans just taught me that
and he said he asked me how I make
meatballs and I was telling him and he
said here's one thing I want you to do I
want you to take your
breadcrumbs and do the milk and egg
separately make like a paste basically
and he goes and then bring that in and I
was like well I don't understand and he
said cuz it's it changes the moisture
sauté your garlic and oil to remove some
of the the the strength and intensity of
it and dump the oil in with the with the
garlic like two tablespoons three
tablespoon oh really so you'll saute
your garlic before it's going into the
meatballs so I otherwise too strong it
takes away I like a strong garlic and a
meatball I like it to like really Punch
Yeah yeah that's me though but I get
that that's not for everybody I have a
little trick do you want to hear
yeah where else we going to go
dude just say it you've done this every
time you want to talk about he's like
we're in an elevator and we're like
about to hit the floor we're supposed to
go to wellz I don't have a lot of tricks
this is one of them no I have I have a
trick with meatballs that I think is
helpful I'm a big believer in
pre-salting red meat of any kind before
you cook it so getting a nice layer of
salt sea salt on red meat letting that
salt sit there for 10 15 minutes exract
some of the moisture create a coat pulls
the flavor out of the meat and it's and
it seeps into the meat and it just you
do that with a
steak I salt a steak 15 minutes before I
cook it both sides
uh and then I'll pepper and and and
garlic one side of it but that salt
thing and letting that salt eat
in it's it's why it's why you'll get
steak in a certain
restaurant that just has great
flavor and then there's another version
of steak you'll get that has no flavor
where you go this just tastes like meat
it needs salt and then the third version
is you'll get a steak that has a salt
flavor but it's a crust yeah the one I
want is the one where you go this looks
like steak and I can't really see
anything on it but holy yeah it's
pops it's because you you pre-s salt the
meat but anyway what I do with my
meatballs is is I take the ground meat
and I I lay it out flat on a pan so it's
even so just you know it's like this
half inch thick whatever and I salt that
evenly and I let that sit and let the
salt eat into that so then your your
meat is evenly salted and then you take
that off put that into the bowl and then
mix and it lets you because it's
otherwise one thing I don't what I what
always drives me nuts when you're making
meatballs what salt is you put that salt
in and you don't really know how evenly
distributed it's being you know once
it's in that bowl you know most times
when you make meatballs everything's
just going in yeah and you're mixing and
salt is the one thing where I'm like you
can't you can't roll the dice on where
that's Landing like you need that to be
evenly d what do you think that I have a
trick do you want to hear it yeah are
you going to try my trick or no no yeah
I would yeah that's a good I like that
straty I just don't I don't I don't
overs salt the steak too long I like to
put I paper towel the E the exterior to
make it drier so that the salt sticks
and it's easier to form a crust I'm more
of the crust guy than than soaking in
salt too long I don't mind a crust but
the problem with a crust is is that you
don't soak it in Salt you give it a
healthy coating there's a learning curve
you're going to oversalt it or you're
going to UND salt it you have to figure
it out but there's there's and you want
a finer salt because the the the coarse
chunks aren't going to seep in whatever
but um but there's a learning curve the
one thing I don't like about crust on a
steak I don't dislike it the thing I why
the reason I prefer the other way is a
lot of the times with the crust it is a
layer of
salt versus the meat having a salt
flavor that I wanted to have yeah yeah
so you know a lot of times if you get
prime rib is a great example because of
the way the prime rib is shaped in the
way you have to cook it a lot of times
you'll get prime rib at a restaurant and
the you you start eating it and you're
like this is
unbelievable then you get to the middle
and you're
like can I get some of that you get that
horseradish that you put on that
like it loses all flavor because there's
nothing getting to the middle of that
stick I only eat Prime ribit like a POS
funeral VFW or some dog like that I
love prime rib dude do you that's like
your choice goto what do we eat at the
steakouse is my go-to but I love it
where what do we get in Vegas the cap
the cap we got the cap of a riy that
sucked that meal what that meal sucked
you didn't like that at all wait the
first night we were there I like this
yeah me you rzy Ari first of all dude I
was I was whacked was no I had no idea I
cursed this much we all did yeah here's
a trick for the meatball outside of the
the breadcrumb you take two forks
opposing because you want to aate the
meat when you mix in your seasonings and
you do a a a light grab and tightening
otherwise it gets you can't over Stir It
Up you Stir It Up with two forks you're
saying you stir with instead of using
your hands and overtightening the meat
that's that's that's good um no no I'm
serious I'm not being a he seems enthal
no I'm saying that's good the worst
podcast ever I was I was circling back
to the reason I was distracted 20
minutes on salting meat that meal this
is great I'll tell you why that meal
sucked I'll tell you why that meal
sucked the next night we went to I'm not
going to call out the place cuz they're
God bless them they do that thing
retroactively suck yeah those those
tater tots were unreal remember the T
said the bacon inside we're the star of
the steak that's the problem dude when
you're sitting there going the tat were
the best thing come on what are we doing
here yeah the waiter was great too
though the waiter was great but we had a
good time we drank a lot of wine but the
next night we went to that old school
Steakhouse that's in the not in Golden
Nugget that's in
um the one uh was it
Harris Harris there's that Steakhouse in
Harris it's like legendary yeah I went
there the next night with TJ Miller and
Paul Italia and Aaron Berg and a couple
other guys and dude we start started
eating in there and I go guys the meal I
had last night sucked this is
unbelievable you didn't have any idea
until you tasted that meal yeah because
I was like this is what I wanted
everything to taste like last night and
it just didn't it just didn't like it
wasn't it just wasn't you got that
didn't you get that weird it was called
the whatever cap cap on a ribeye which I
never even knew was like a thing oh it's
the best piece of meat you can ever have
cuz they cuz the only two steakhouses
where I've ever seen it offered were
that place and this other place I'm
talking about right now I want to say
Oscars um that was the only two times
I've ever seen the cap on the menu deal
fat to meat ratio just on that outside
so you so maybe you're maybe that was
good cuz I didn't get the cap I just got
I think I got a strip steak or something
that's all right but it was what I'm
talking about it wasn't a bad piece of
meat it was just like I was like there's
it doesn't it needs flavor it doesn't
like the when I start if you if I'm
eating steak with you I'm just imagine
him so drunk he's like drooling at the
table I was hammered
there's no flavor in it's like dude
you're barely experiencing any part of
the world right now if you if I'm eating
steak with you and you see me start
dipping my steak into the cream spinach
on my that's that it's because I'm like
the steak doesn't have any flavor in it
man like it needs something first bite
of the steak you you got to go just
straight up right you never put any
fixings on no I don't put you should
never have to put fixings on that's what
I'm saying if you don't do this after
the first bike it sucks
ready
you don't do that if if if F if you
don't do that after first it sucks up to
her knees and the wavs huh you're acting
a lot of work coming in by what acting
agent do you not do that after when you
when you s i curse of course I go
Jesus you haven't eaten in days you're
you're trying the best steak in the
world when you you see I'm serious do
you ever see Defending Your Life fix
with good pants did you ever see
Defending Your Life yeah did you ever
see the movie Defending Your Life no of
course not this kid got shut the up what
other movies you want to talk Defending
Your Life who's in that Albert Albert
Brooks one of the comedy Titans seen
you've definitely seen it You'
definitely seen it he it's he goes to
this place called he dies and he goes to
this place called judgment City and it's
where you go to find out if you get to
move on to the next life yeah and the
thing in Jud one of the things in
judgment city is every restaurant no
matter what you order it's the best
version of it that you've ever had and
it's and it's instantly ready and you
can have as much of it as you want and
it's all free yeah cuz wouldn't that be
heaven and every every scene it's so
funny every scene dude he takes a bite
of something that he
goes every single time cuz he's like
this is crazy and I'm dead serious if
you don't do that after you bite a steak
and a St dude these placees aren't cheap
you're paying 60 70 sometimes 85 hours
for I know you better be amazing yeah
you're going to bust my Nookies about
this but I get legitimately upset when
something is really good like it's the
same reaction internally like the
mechanism firing off in my my my scull
is anger cuz I can't put together the
words or emotions about how good this
food is yeah it's great it's great do
you laugh so when the waiter comes over
like how is everything he's looking at
me going oh is fighting with his
girlfriend and it's like this is so
goddamn good yeah unbelievable I laugh I
start laughing some yeah I do that I get
like I get like
Mania you don't know what to do yeah
yeah it's a it's awesome it's awesome
you also Chris it's a food podcast I
don't know if you knew that yeah you're
putting so much pressure on talking
about Stak kid going when do we get to
talk about
Cheetos I like a good Cheetos yeah all
right listen we got to get to the battle
40 some minutes in here we got to get to
the battle the battle today we have
teased this battle for quite some time
and I'm glad we finally got to do it who
the show we've talked for some time
about doing an Tim's
battle and oh that's why you threw this
on us well I no here's why I threw it on
you when you both texted me your food
lists yeah you both mentioned entiments
I didn't say anything about entiments
I'll pull it up right now I said I said
do you no no oh I'm sorry he mentioned
timens and I went oh we timens
battle we've been trying to do and then
I said to you do you like timens and you
said I would slit my mother's throat for
the crumb donut well that was because I
hated her when I was eating Crum
donut fair
enough but I said all right and then I
went back to Chris I said which which
which timens would you like ride or die
for you said the crumb cake crumb cake
for sure and then I went back to Tommy
and I said Tommy do the do donuts just
do the an Donuts is okay and I said and
my my rider die is the raspberry twist I
mean it's I don't even know what that is
it's nice it actually is kind of nice
it's got the glaze over it and it's like
it's undulation of the it's like a long
doughnut that's all ripped up by a bear
claw V can we get a picture of the
raspberry twist so the raspberry twist
is we were talking raspberry in the
gullies oh God it's so good so yeah it's
I don't know what style of cake that is
oh I hate this good cuz it's the
best thing they made it
sucks I hate this jelly thing I hate
jelly in Donuts I hate jelly in Donuts I
hate this type of if it was just
drizzled on the top and you got like a
light little jelly flavor I'd be like
fine really this is an uncomparable
amount of jelly flavor yeah that's too
much there's two drips on the you can't
handle this amount of jelly no this is I
get mad at it cuz there's not enough of
the raspberry sometimes this is the kind
of cake you'd have like your dad would
have to get a raise at Sears like if
this is on your counter you have a
healthy relationship with your wife this
was this was a this was a staple growing
up back when same my father was nuts
about it Sebastian had the bit in his
second or third special about company
when you have company come over yeah and
he goes he goes we kept a can of Sanka
and an timans just in case company came
over this was our on hand and Tim for
company now this is the thing this was
so
good when I was a kid and i' I've said
this on this podcast I believe this was
so good when I was a kid that when my
mom I said can we please please can we
get the the thing with the Jelly in it
Whatever She's like Yeah she bought it
and showed it to me I go that's not it
and she goes this is it I go there's no
way that's raspberry there's no way I
was so convinced that'd be cherry or
strawberry cuz those are the only two
red fruit flavors I knew and she's like
this is it and I couldn't wrap my head
around it to this day I'm still kind of
shocked
but this
cake this just dog Army Food huh
this is terrible enman this is genuine
dog
enman is enman is I I understand
it's store-bought dessert goes it's you
they're the Kings yeah but when you get
past 13
18 as an adult you can't be consuming
this yes you can the an I barely ever
eat timens anymore because I for the
same reason I don't eat Twinkies a lot
you know it's like eat ilos in New York
like there's other WKA block well now
but here's the thing here's where I
would disagree with you there's good
versions of fast and cheap and there's
bad versions of it yeah timans is a very
good version of it I get that we all
live around gourmet restaurants but
sometimes you want a Whopper and you go
get get a Whopper and the Whopper is
awesome there's a good version of fast
and cheap 100% timans is the bakery
version of fast and cheap they are the
McDonald's of fast and cheap baked goods
and they do it dude nobody nobody in
that package cake aisle in the
supermarket is doing what timens is do
nobody it's true it's true nobody's
coming even close dude that there a
distant second is like what uh uh is
Gourmet past Gourmet pastries I would
say are dis who makes who makes like a
devil dog not ha host host yeah well
they're going the same place you're
eventually yourself Hostess is
a distant second like it's like this is
not the coffeee cake I'm talking about
by the way no no no you mean the crumb
cake yes yeah that one is awesome though
it's not bad but I mean I can't think of
another brand can you think of another
brand in the supermarket that is making
full cakes and
pies it's wild right and by the way by
the way if you gave me the choice
between timens and and the package stuff
that the store makes nine times out of
10 I would take the timans over that
because I know it and I can trust it
those little blueberry muffins that
Hostess puts in a pouch oh the three
lights out dude pretty lights out pretty
those are good but you do love the crumb
cake donut which is why you're defending
their donut crake donut out of all
little bites that's it that's entiments
yeah entim they're fantastic dude that
changed the bus we should change the
change the B we should have had you
defend the little bites I didn't know
what was GNA happen it Donuts you didn't
understand when I said picking entiments
yeah what that meant obious only going
to be Donuts I don't F see these rich
chocolate Frost Elite terrible you're
nuts look if you look at the mix box
here's why I pick the ones with nipples
on no cuz you dip it in the milk and the
the the icing is so fake that it doesn't
do anything it's so robust plastic
chocolate plastic into the donut let me
get to the crumbs the crumbs out of the
four pack it would be plain if you're
eating plain yourself then it'd be the
crumb then it'd be the plastic chocolate
and then a cinnamon powder yeah and I
didn't love the powdered everybody went
my my dad my brothers my mom if that if
you saw my mom come out with like WWA
bags first thing you want you dig in and
you get the the enman what's it called
crumb yeah that you that's the first
pick but that variety pack is very
exciting 100% that variety pack I don't
share your s This Is wealth you're
getting a whole a whole box yes I don't
sh yes I'm with you I don't share your
sentiment on um I don't share your
sentiment
on the uh other flavors I actually love
the chocolate frosted uh you can taste
the chemicals in the chocolate frosting
I don't think so I don't it doesn't tast
chemic no it just tastes like ch but
that that tastes like childhood to me
yeah nostalgic I get that but here's
Tommy here's what I disagree with you
and maybe you'll agree with me Chris cuz
you like the chocolate frosted you told
me I love it okay it doesn't taste
chemically to me what it tastes like is
timin's period across the board they
have a particular flavor that they do
yeah timans does have a flavor profile
that they stick with so in other words
the chocolate on that dut the flavor of
the chocolate if you get a chocolate I
of chocolate frosted chocolate cake from
them and has a similar flavor and it's
not chemically to me it's it's just like
no this is what timon's chocolate tastes
like how long canity to it it doesn't
melt on your fingers I there's a reason
for that I'll prove you wrong not long I
I cuz I used to buy the packs of just
the chocolate frosted I used to love
those things they went stale pretty
quick yeah but they don't go bad they're
not getting like mold and all that stuff
there's no moisture to the my point is
is though it went they went they went
unedible yeah you know like yeah I mean
what I'm not I wasn't keeping them to
see what they would grow but like yeah
after a few days they'd be like these
are done like this is it it's over did
you ever open a box of timon's wrong cuz
they have the little the little
perforated part do you ever open it
wrong and you rip the whole box open and
you're like I got to eat the whole thing
dud they
I I recently bought a box of chocolate
frosted and they they made uh Innovation
there's there's a little lip now on the
side that you punch in before you open
it really yes that cuz you every time
you open the rich chocolate frosted the
whole side would explode there was
almost no way to avoid it it was like
you'd have to get like a n you'd have to
like heat it with a hair dryer and then
like use a knife to cut it open just
think of how many six-year-old
waterheads are still blasting through
the front of the Box not I almost did
and then I saw the perforation the new
perforation on the side I was I remember
I moved once uh once I Mo when when I
moved from La back to New York it was
the most stressful time of my life you
guys want to hear it yeah I'm going to
tell it to you the uh no it was the uh
it was the brokest I ever was in my life
I had no money I had to put all the move
on on credit
cards uh I had slept out of a bed for
over a month because of the way the
moving was TimeWise and it was horrible
I got to New
York all my stuff was late it was buted
right up against Christmas it was it was
the darkest most stressful period of my
life not just because of the move I just
mean like everything was going on
financially I just had it was horrible
and I was so depressed I remember I was
in this apartment that had basically no
windows in it that I ended up getting
stuck in during the lockdown uh I was in
that apartment I would wake
up on this on this
like like chair that I had cuz cuz cuz
the bed hadn't showed up like a recliner
like I guess I it was some kind of chair
I can't remember cuz I don't have it
anymore I don't I don't think I reclined
I think it Jesus Christ what read a
diary get to anyway so what a strange
I'd wake up on that I'd wake up on that
chair in the morning but you couldn't
tell cuz there was no
windows and I would just I I and I and
there was just boxes of everywhere
I don't back and I would reach over
always without fail it was right there
bottle of red wine and a chocolate
entiments cake oh my God and I would
reach over and grab it and just start
eating it and drinking the
wine as soon as I open my
eyes it was horrible it was a bad time
yeah dude I like then Co
happened my world changed yeah dude
that's this is kind of why I have't I
was just going to say that the the
timans like that sheet crumb cake that
lasagna and orange juice are like a key
to a solid two week depression for me
yeah yeah yeah like I'm sad now are you
drinking orange juice with the crumb
cake yeah shock to the system I have a
friend that used to do that he would
drink exclusively he had a he was a
cookie he loved cookies so much he would
have I'm not kidding when we lived
together we were roommates he used to
have at any given time six six bags of
cookies in rotation he'd have like he'd
have like an extra chunky uh chips chips
a Hoy he'd have some kind of toll housee
Keebler elves why not be baking your own
we were like 22 okay he'd have a
stelladoro like two times of stor right
and he would every night he would eat
cookies before he went to bed and he
would drink orange juice with it oh my
God and that was his move man is he
alive yeah Jesus yeah that's just
depression I have an unhealthy
relationship Chris will tell you with
like sugars like bags of gummy bears
every night shitload of chocolate love
cookies unhealthy relationship with
donuts because I feel like it's a sad
person's Resort like when I see a person
eating a donut in the daytime walking
you hate the aesthetic so sad for him
and eat if I see a dude licking an ice
cream conon by himself and he's an adult
I'd rather you stick a heroin needle up
your ass dude it's the weird like get
under a bridge and hide that there is
something about
Donuts there's something about Donuts
when that's outside of sitting around
the table with coffee yes there's so sad
yeah there is something about now when
gu sitting at a counter just eating
Donuts that's rough dude that's rough I
told Tommy a story I was in Vancouver
and I like yeah I got up I got up early
in Vancouver cuz we were only there for
like 12 hours and I was I just want to
see the bay and I got up and I got
myself a doughnut and was walking around
and I was about to take a bite of this
dut I swe seagull the size of like a
laborador game and hit me and took the
dut
and literally just stopped in front of
me with the dut in its mouth and was
just like so crazy just slowly pull out
a revolver I tell him I tell him the
story and he goes you were eating a fing
dut
in so pathetic what the is wrong
with I I uh I'm a dut head I will eat I
will eat um now I like now when it comes
intiments I prefer the raspberry twist
but I do love donuts and I will
eat I will eat I talked to St burned
about this once I was like how many
donuts in one swoop will you
do and we were going between three and
four in one SW like fulls size Donuts
yeah and I told that to sa once I said
I'll on average I'll eat three donuts
and he really like had a problem with it
he was he thought it was like crazy I
was like it's not that crazy I'm like
are you talking about like to replace a
whole meal or is this in between me no
I'm saying if if I got my if my sweet
tooth gets going and I'm like I I I'm
going to indulge today and eat some
donuts I'm like yeah prob eat like three
Donuts that's crazy yeah it's not crazy
it's like sayg it's no worse than eating
a sugar wise it's the same as eating a
bag of Gummy Bears I don't think so how
big is a
bag you never ate twoo but the the
psychology the psychology is totally
different because gummy bears you're
eating just one at a time you're like
you can slowly you look down before you
know it the bag's gone you don't get
three that's three separate choices
pieces of cake would you eat three
pieces of cake at a party that a
doughnut is not the same as a piece of
cake that's because you're by yourself
being sad hiding shame a donut is not
the same as a piece of cake a piece of
cake is is more substantial different
shap cake Circle cake it's it's smaller
than
cake it's smaller than cake I don't know
I think it's the same dude first of all
I'm not even being funny there's a hole
in the middle of it first of all second
of all this is this is the psychology of
someone who's got a problem no no no you
take there's a whole hole in the middle
you take half of it is isn't even there
yeah you take a no no I'm telling you
you it's like saying it's like saying
spaghetti is the same as lasagna it's
not it's not it's just not
man but dude if you take if you get a a
glazed donut from Dunkin Donuts you'll
get three of those it's no I'll get one
and then two other things I'm saying
it's like that is not like a piece of
cake dude a piece of cake is heavy dude
it's it's dense like what about uh um um
what's a popular doughnut glazed
donut crispy creams how many crispy I
wouldn't cross the street for a Crispy
Cream I think they're disgusting they're
a million times better than any donut
they're not you're dumb and you're
stupid they suck they just taste like
sugar they have no Nuance to their
flavor that's the whole purpose no it's
not the whole purpose a dut no they have
no Nu you love these timen's Donuts
because they have there's there's a cake
element in the bottom
frosting element there's the crumbs have
a different flavor there's a powdered
sugar there's different flavors are good
I'll be Ser coconut crunch coconut
crunch from Dunkin' Donuts is the only
do your final Insanity we're digressing
into Donuts in general but but I want
you to real quick we'll go around really
quick give your final argument on why
the timan donuts are the best thing if
you're going to buy timin seriously like
why my donut is the best donut just if
you're going to go timin why do you why
do you say go donuts over hard is giving
a about something you don't give a
about you do give a you said
they were the first thing you reached in
the bag that's why I said it's the
tallest syndrome I'm going for
that one cuz it's the best of the bun
little person little person syndrome
yeah learn how to talk well yeah you're
40 I'm
44 that's even
worse uh no AR all right I'll I'll argue
the one with the nipples on it is
because every bite you're getting
different textures and when you're done
cuz I'm not a monster I don't eat two
more okay cuz I've loved ones and I have
respect for people right you can pick up
the little nipples that fall off kind of
fun okay they could double as little
candy toss okay you'll eat only one of
those that's it you don't need two no
raised well full of you're full of
dude Joe I'll do it in front of
you I will have one go guy that loves
food as much as you doesn't eat one
donut I don't eat a lot of food when I
eat eat that much just said you eat a
whole family-sized bag of Gummy Bears
every night that's not
food all right get his ass Chris what
what closing arguments on why the crumb
cake is because you I don't even think
you ever said to begin with it's the
best it's the best to me of texture
ratio like the the doughiness of the
cake cuz it is different from the dut
version 100% the donut is Airy and
shitty like you're talking about the the
cake itself is dense and thick it does
feel like actual cake the crumbs on top
are perfect and to me the best part is
when you get the whole sheet you can
control your portions all right you can
I like that you can I like that now
we've we've argued we've argued coffee
cake in general yeah did that go well
yeah we've argued we've argued coffee
cake on here all right all right all
right I I think I argued it all right I
like it yeah I get it I get it no no no
guys are too self-conscious man you want
me to I like it already rub your balls
after everything you said you think I
haven't heard it before I'm on episode
300 of this show I've heard it all well
you put yourself in this box yeah the uh
sorry for all the bleeps pimp the uh
anyway we've argued crumb cake that was
a diing me no it was I just cursed oh
you guys are so up your own asses it's
unbelievable you talking unbelievable
the ego W off how did Shane's ego stay
behind and infect the if you're going to
hurt us do it be creative no no no what
I was going to say about I was going to
add on to what you said about crumb cake
okay we've I've actually argued on
behalf of coffee cake on this show I
think it was with Koo I can't remember
what he defended just in general yeah
what I like about a crumb cake and a
coffee cake is it's very I feel like
it's like it's like Teamster business is
getting done you know what I mean that's
a cake you put down the guys you're in
suits like we're going to be till 4:00
a.m. hashing this out I also feel that
way about Donuts I can't say the same
for the raspberry
twist the raspberry twist is more of a
you're going into uh you know a cordoy
shop you're going into kah hawen you
know what I mean maybe uh Frankfurt
where I'm from Northeast Philly is my
point you're going into no Cotman Cotman
Avenue Russian polish trash you're going
into Nona territory and you're sitting
down but ain't nothing wrong with nona
territory it's just different territory
that feels like you wanted to get a nice
Italian pastry and the place was closed
or moved locations and you got that
instead love I disagree I think it's the
best thing that that that that entiments
does again let's talk texture uh as you
guys did I like that it has an airiness
to cake I like that it also has a white
frosting on it that is gives it a hard
uh bit of a crust to it and then the
jelly of course is is is a whole
different sensation and there's also
correct me if I'm wrong there's like
bumpy stuff on it too it's it's the
ridges and The Cook The Cook puts
different textures it's like four Donuts
in one yes it is you I mean it's like a
jelly donut it's a it's a ice Frost
doughnut it's a crumb cake cuz my second
doughnut that I get is always a jelly
yeah wow okay all right that's good very
good guys plug whatever you want to plug
before we go uh before we go to the vote
here uh just stuff Island yeah stuff
Island YouTube go to stuff Island our
YouTube we got a patreon we got over
over 200 we're catching up 200 episodes
we do a cooking show called look at Dish
sign up on our $10 look at dish tier to
get all of our 25 26 episodes nice nice
these guys are the best I love them I
really have fun uh you guys really make
me laugh uh so come do the cooking show
I'll come do both shows yeah I I
apologize that it hasn't happened yet um
but I really really love these guys
watch uh the cooking show and listen to
stuff Island stuff Island video too I
for okay so watch stuff is listen to
stuff Island support these two guys yeah
they're great um oh and also too if if
if if the stuff is still out there watch
the Delco proper stuff that you did
awesome oh my God are you in Delco
proper at all no um I didn't think so
but I just I couldn't remember exactly
and then I would have felt bad if I left
it out I'm sorry uh anyway watch these
guys they're both great standups too by
the way so check that out um all right
here's how this works we're going to
pick one we're going to reveal feel who
won whoever wins has to say to the other
two guys I still love you and then the
other two guys go I love you too and
that's it that's the end of the show
that's the button every time that's it
here we go ready we got 5,500 votes
these going to Crum cake holy Donut
oh my God oh my God I got cream that's
me oh my God I'm the winner it's yeah
crumb cake proper takes
31.9% raspberry twist got
.8% that might be the most I've ever
lost and donuts
59% the thing you said you didn't care
about took it like a champ let's go
Tommy Pope champion of taste bu let's go
um it's okay guys I still love you it's
a flawed love you it's a flawed that's
the end no no no remember how I said
this is how it end no it's a flawed Pole
it's over you have to say it Chris and
look me in the eyes it's I still love
you but that's a flawed poll you know it
is you supposed to say I love you too
cut
it taste buds they com to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools going
to fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they coming to The
Taste Buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about